foreign
saving drug that can rapidly reverse an
opioid overdose will soon be available
widely the FDA approved over-the-counter
sales of Narcan is what it's called now
according to the drug maker listen to
these numbers one person dies from an
opioid overdose roughly every eight
minutes
wow the CDC says more than 100 000
Americans died in the 12 months from
October 2021. the FDA approval allows
Narcan to be sold directly to consumers
in drugstores grocery stores gas
stations even and even online CBS News
medical contributor Dr Celine gounder
joins us now she's also by the way
editor at large for public health at kff
good morning to you Dr Celine two days
in a row I say lucky us that we get you
here at the table this sounds like a
really significant deal is it if you
look at life expectancy rates around the
world the reason or one of the reasons
the United States has much lower life
expectancy rate than comparable
high-income countries is drug overdoses
so when I heard the news I thought oh
this is great news but then I started to
think through what is it going to mean
for people trying to access it and it's
really going to depend on how is this
going to be priced we're only talking
about the brand name Narcan not generic
naloxone and will insurance companies
cover it so that's going to really
determine whether people are able to
access it but the fact that they're now
allowing it to be readily available so
that they're very concerned about those
no I was blown away by the numbers that
I just read the numbers are startling
and so if we can make this available
where people can have it in every purse
backpack in every school and every
family first aid kit it really could
make a very big difference I've actually
only seen a paramedic administer Narcan
and it's amazing the effect it's pretty
rapid but so Ray regular people though
can use this it's simple enough to use
it's very easy I mean a lot of us have
used those nasal sprays for allergies
it's really just that easy to use yeah
but if you're using drugs you got to
make sure that there's somebody with you
that's competent enough and coherent
enough to give it to you we often advise
our patients to use with a buddy so your
buddy is not supposed to be using at the
same time as you so they can look out
for you so that if you overdose there's
somebody there who's looking out for you
with Narcan at hand or ability to call
9-1-1 I don't know why that just throws
I think it says if you're going to use
drugs used with a buddy I think I think
it's like having somebody designated
things
it's chemical dependency and in their
withdrawals if you don't but so I think
it's it's don't use if you can but yeah
exactly how do you recognize when
someone is having an overview
well they might be slumped over they
might be passed out their pin pupils are
pinpoint really tiny they might be
breathing really slowly or their lips
might even be blue fingernails blue you
said that you first thought good good
idea and then you start thinking about
the price we don't know the price yet
because that's important the price is
really important if we're talking about
a hundred dollars to buy a box of Narcan
that's going to be out of the range for
a lot of people and typically
over-the-counter drugs are not covered
by Insurance to get access to the
generic naloxone you would still need a
prescription which could be covered by
insurance but then that defeats the
purpose of it being over the counter and
more easily accessible and how soon will
we possibly see this happening you can
get it yeah the drug company is saying
probably late summer that
over-the-counter Narcan would be
available well it seems like this is
life-changing for the crisis
Dr sling under thank you so much